Our people are scattered
like stars in the galaxy.
What are we?
What do we stand for?
Hang on kid.
This is the way.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie.
This will be my Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 4 Video.
They released a new footage,
and there are a bunch of big cliffhangers
they left on to pay off.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes
and careful spoilers for everything
that's happened so far.
If you're not caught up
at the end of episode three, though,
Bo-Katan looked like she'd
finally gotten her wish for her family,
but maybe accidentally joining Mando's
cult the watch like she was really quiet.
They're like,
Wait a minute, what just happened?
It's like something out of Arrested
Development in space.
Bo-Katan suddenly realized
she may have just joined her boyfriend.
Space called.
You may leave any time you wish.
We finally have some context
for these scenes of the Armor's
group all attacking on this planet here.
It seems that they're dropping out of Boka
Tan's Mandalorian ship
because now she's working with them.
She's now part of their cover.
So by episode four,
she's busy going on missions with them.
You can let me know in the comments
who you think they're
attacking on this planet,
because it looks kind of like Navarro.
As much as we joke about the armors group
being so hardcore,
Katy Sackhoff actually said in real life,
one of the big things with Bo-Katan
this season is that
she's been living in her families
ancestral palace on their Homeworld
collab all Alone,
the one that just got destroyed
by the Empire
since the end of Mandalorian season
two alone.
Like she'd been living there by herself
the whole time.
She even complained to Mando about that.
I want to be alone.
Leave me alone.
But Katy
Sackhoff said what was really going on.
What you didn't actually see on screen
was that she had been so angry at Mando,
talking about wanting to be alone because
she did not want to be alone like it was.
A lady doth protest too much situation.
She really did want the family
because she believed the night
owls were her family
and they deserted her, basically.
So it's not so much about Bo-Katan
wanting all this power
because people are wondering
about what's going on with the Darksaber.
Does she still want that?
Is she trying to take over the armors
group now, at least according to Katee
Sackhoff, it's more about Bo-Katan
finding the family that she felt like
she lost.
We've been making all the jokes
the last couple of episodes
about her being grogu's new space mom,
making him
all kinds of Mandalorian treats
all that POG soup mando's like in space.
Darth even posted some promos of her
at Disneyland with Mando,
like mom and dad taking the kid
to Disneyland in the whole idea
is, at the end of episode three,
she basically gets that family.
For those of you also asking
if Grogu who is going to speak,
actually talked this season.
The way that Jon Favreau talks about it
is that Grogu might already be speaking.
So I think the gurgling sounds
that he made in episode
three is the closest we'll see to him
actually speaking this season.
Like he'll
just do more of that kind of stuff.
But a big part,
especially in Episode four,
I think, is the idea that she's
going to want to win back the Night Owls
because she still wants to retake
the planet Mandalore from the Empire
and fight the empire itself.
That's
where the real dichotomy between her
and the armor is like,
even though
she's coming around on the way,
so to speak,
like this is the way she saw the mythos.
Or according to Katee Sackhoff,
that's still genuine.
She's slowly coming around
believing in their line of thought,
but she hasn't like completely done
a 180 yet.
She's still skeptical about
some of their more hard core beliefs.
Like,
do we really need to keep our helmets
on this entire time, Dwight,
to sleep with this helmet on?
If you remember,
they are allowed to take their helmets off
as long as they're by themselves.
And if they become married pairs
inside their sect,
they're they can take their helmets off
when they're together getting it on.
But the whole idea is that she came back
at the end of season two to the Night
Owls on Call of all of their
where they've been living.
They saw that
she didn't have the darksaber.
They didn't believe that
she was a worthy leader anymore
and decided to take all the imperial ships
they'd stolen already and go off
and just be mercenaries
in a different part of the outer rim.
So big faction of the night Owls
are still out there somewhere
and they're going to track them down,
try to win them over to probably using
Mando and the Darksaber as well.
Now that Bo-Katan
is working with Mando more.
But as you can see
in all the trailer footage
so far in all the previous episodes,
nothing Mando has said up to this point
makes it seem like he cares
about retaking the planet Mandalore.
He's not thinking about becoming
the new mandalore leader of their people
because the leader of their people
who wields the darksaber per
their rules is called the new Mandalore
after Mandalore the Great.
Up to this point, Mando
had just been thinking about reclaiming
his honor, bathing in the living waters
and going back to regular bounty
hunting work.
So I think the ideas in episode
four and future episodes
Bo-Katan will slowly start to try
and win him over to her line of thought,
and they'll try to balance out
the Armor's beliefs with Bogota's believes
in the big dichotomy
there is that the Armor
also hadn't really thought
about retaking the planet yet.
She believed
that Mandalore had been coerced
and even told Mando
it wasn't possible to win his honor back.
Like, No, you can't do it.
And he proved her wrong,
so she'll probably start to come around.
On Bo-Katan slaying
the thought by the end of the season too.
Like maybe we can't fight the empire
and retake the planet.
So for those people that are wondering
if Bo-Katan is doing something
kind of shady, like slowly
trying to take over the armors group,
I don't think that's exactly
what she has planned right now.
I do think she and the armor will wind up
fighting at some point
for different reasons
because she's only starting
to believe in their customs and legends.
But I think it will be more of her
just basic differences of opinion
like this is what we should be doing.
There's a bunch of new trailer footage
of all the mandalorians from the armors
group going on a mission together
on what seems like the same planet
as the terrain from the planet
seems the same.
You see them all
using their jetpacks together,
so it seems like they do start
going on missions
together and Bo-Katan starts
working with them on the same missions.
But like I said, the next big step
for them is to win the support
of the night owls.
Like we have this whole other faction
with a bunch of imperial ships,
a bunch of power.
We could use the extra juice
from their group to fight the empire.
But right now the armors group
isn't really thinking about that.
So Bo-Katan has to slowly
win them over to that idea.
Like, it's totally possible
we can fight the Empire
as long as we have
all the mandalorians together
and we have somebody who has the darksaber
right now,
I do think they will actually go back
to the planet mandalore at some point
and get that mythos or like they will ride
that mythos or at some point.
I also don't think that she was hiding
the knowledge of the mythos
or for shady reasons.
I think it just her slowly trying
to think things through in her head like,
what does this all mean?
Is this all true, all these legends
and myths about our people?
We also see some more footage of Mando
flying in this debut Starfighter
Dogfighting with green Shards
pirate ships.
Mando destroyed some of his ships
and escape at the end of episode one.
So of course, he was going to come back.
There's also rumors the gory and charred
character is going to be a bigger villain
during the Star Wars Skeleton Crew series.
Later this year.
Like the Star Wars,
people have bigger plans for the Gory
and Shard character
to make him a bigger villain in future
series.
The Skeleton Crew series
is that Jude Law series, which is also
meant to be a spinoff of The Mandalorian,
but is supposed to cover
an entirely different part of the galaxy.
For those of you thinking there's
some secret connection
between Bo-Katan and the armor,
I definitely think
that you're on to something.
I do think they have history together
because the Armor knew exactly who she was
when she stepped into the room,
like, Hello, Bo-Katan.
We meet again.
There's lots of theories about them
being biologically related.
I talked about that in my episode
three video because during the Clone Wars
they tease that Bo-Katan
and the teen had a mystery third sister
that they never really explained.
The whole idea is that
Korkie was their nephew, meaning
that they had to have another sister
and they just never followed up on that.
So sort of an open plot thread for them
to play
with during the events of The Mandalorian
if they want to.
It's also possible
the armor is just someone
who is really close to Bo-Katan,
even if they're not
part of the same family.
I talked about the Easter eggs
with the Paz vizsla character
who's Jon Favreau's new character
in the connection to previously
during the Clone Wars with Bo-Katan.
So that's why the previously character
was staring at Bo-Katan.
So much during episode three,
just because he remembers her probably
from the events of the Clone Wars
and her connection with his either
father or relative.
They'll probably have some fight later
this season, like they're probably teasing
some conflict between the two of them.
Also.
Episode four
I don't know that the follow up on this
till episode five or future episodes,
but on the empire side of things
where that cliffhanger
where they follow up on Moff Gideon
Escape plan with the help of Elliott Cain,
I explained her long term plan.
She even planned to throw Dr.
Pershing under the bus to get herself
closer to where Moff Gideon
is being held inside the New Republic
so that she can help him escape.
They also have to explain more
of what's going on with Grand
Admiral Thrawn and Ahsoka this season.
The Ahsoka
storyline is tied to the Thrawn storyline,
as is the Ezra Bridger storyline,
but a lot of that will probably leave
for the Ahsoka episodes later this year.
I think we'll only continue to get teasers
for Thrawn in the Seventh Fleet
during The Mandalorian.
I talked about that during episode three.
The reason why
these Tiner setters and the TY bombers
probably belong to Thrawn seventh Fleet
is because there's way too many of them
to be Moff Gideon sources.
Most of those were taken
by the New Republic
after he was captured
at the end of season two.
So all the extra imperial forces
like this giant mystery fleet
would belong to Thrawn.
When we see Ahsoka
and maybe Sabine Wren show up this season
in cameo scenes, they'll probably explain
Thrawn is returning a little bit more.
Ezra Bridges return
and just help set up the Ahsoka episodes,
But I'm not expecting to see Thrawn
on screen or Ezra Bridger on screen.
Like the live action versions of
the characters until the Ahsoka episodes.
We'll see those. There's always a chance
that they could cameo too.
I just did a big Thrawn video
about what's going on
with him in this part of the galaxy,
how he was able to return
from the unknown regions
and what his backstory is in the live
action Star Wars universe now.
So think that at the end of this
and down the description below,
but if there's any questions
you have or any Easter eggs
you spotted in the trailer
so far are cliffhangers
that you're not sure about,
just write them below in the comments
and I'll address them in my future.
Bonus videos.
I've got a couple more planned this week
in my full season three Episode four Video
we'll post next week
after they release it.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone
click here for My Full Mandalorian Season
three Episode
three Video and click here to learn
what's going on with Grand Admiral Thrawn
right now on The Mandalorian.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.